everyone is ignoring probably the most  pertinent fact for the 2024 presidential  race and it was demonstrated in a clip  that was going viral around the internet  yesterday it was a clip from one of  trump's old speeches mashed up with a  little bit of music just take a listen  they want to ban straws  has anybody ever tried those paper  stores they're not working  right  they want to ban straws i said well you  know i've had  a couple of  meals at mcdonald's etc over the years  wendy's friend of mine owns wendy's i'll  give it a plug right what's the deal  with these paper stores this is  trump's secret weapon and i think it  very well could be decisive in 2024 it  certainly was decisive in 2016. trump is  so freaking entertaining he's so  funny the man is captivating he has star  quality and i'm not saying that's a good  thing and i'm not saying it's a bad  thing i'm just telling you what it is